what a wonderful opportunity that we
have ahead of us here
we are at the threshold of a very
very important chance a crucial chance
for us to redeem ourselves with allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala it's the month of
repentance it's the month of fasting
it's the month of prayer but most
importantly it is the month of the quran
that's what allah called it in the quran
he said
the month of ramadan and he defined it
as saying
in which the quran was revealed
so
we really need to not only fast not only
pray not only be good but really focus
on the quran and hone in on its meanings
so
in light of this i am excited to
invite everyone
for us to meet every day after salah
we will have a series throughout the
days of ramadan every single day
after salah
we will be discussing
the tafsir of surat al-anbiya the 21st
chapter of the quran why this chapter
this chapter
mentions the center thrust and the main
point
and the fulcrum
upon which everything else in islam is
hinged it mentions the commonalities
between the
calling and the religion of all of the
prophets and the messengers it is a
crucial chapter and we are going to look
at it insha'allah under a different
light
through a different lens hopefully that
we can almost kind of see it for the
first time
and
as usual it will be presented mainly in
english there will be some arabic as
well spoken and it's very important for
us to focus on the quran
it's very important for us during this
month to make the quran the
absolute center of our thought and our
being we need to meditate over its
meanings we need to contemplate them
reflect and hopefully this light will
spill through our hearts and bring out a
better person in all of us bring out our
hope and reason so
join us
every day after swallow
in surat al-anbiya it's very exciting
very important for us to join this
thank you very much may allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala bring out the best in every
one of us during this month and grant us
our full potential
as foreign